ja in dieser zweiten Folge des Seminars
philosophische Theorien der Aufklärung
geht es um Rousseau Georgia Cousin der
hat gelebt von 1712 bis 1778 ungefähr im
Zeitalter von David Hume und auch
Immanuel Kant ist im 18 Jahrhundert
geboren als es ist ein Jahrhunderte
Aufklärung des 18 Jahrhunderts und er
hat ein ganz bekanntes Werk geschrieben
eine Abhandlung über die Wissenschaften
und die Künste aus dem Jahr 1750 war der
gute Mann 38 Jahre alt
und es war genau genommen eine
Preisschrift auf die Preisfrage die die
Akademie von Dijon gestellt hat und
diese
Preisfrage lautete hat die
Wiederherstellung der Wissenschaften und
Künste dazu beigetragen die Sitten zu
läutern also es geht um das Verhältnis
von Wissenschaft von kultureller
Entwicklung und moralische Entwicklungen
sind die
letztendlich
proportional zueinander zu verstehen
also je mehr Wissenschaft je mehr Kultur
desto mehr Sitten oder vielleicht sogar
antiproportional also je mehr Kultur je
mehr Wissenschaft desto weniger
Sitten und Moral und für diese letzte
these für diese
antiproportionalitätsthese argumentiert
und so er verneint die Frage in seinem
diskur
zu dieser Preisschrift in Genf
erschienen 1750
und was sagt jetzt so hier er stellt
seinen
Preisschrift ein lateinisches
Motor voran mit dem Titel die keepingurs
BC recti das heißt so viel wie wir
täuschen uns
unter dem Schein des rechten also wir
täuschen uns indem wir denken wir tun
das Richtige und das ist eine
interessante Feststellung dieses Zitat
ist schon älter kommt aus den alten
Latein und
er möchte jetzt hier eine Position
einnehmen die sich für einen ehrenhaften
Mann gezielt der nichts weiß sich
deshalb aber selbst nicht weniger
schätzt dieser Bezug ist wie mir scheint
der Bezug auf Sokrates Sokrates hat
bekanntlich gesagt ich weiß dass ich
nichts weiß also wozu gibt sich hier
sehr bescheiden man könnte auch fast
sagen ganz natürlich und gar nicht
künstlich geht's ja um die Frage um die
Abhandlung über die Wissenschaften und
die Künstler er möchte hier gerade nicht
künstlich sondern natürlich
erscheinen und sagt das gleich zu Beginn
erlaubt wird der Gegensatz von Natur und
Kunst in diesem diese Abhandlung eine
große Rolle spielt
man muss so erweist in diese Abhandlung
als ein
Kulturkritiker der die herrschenden
Zustände
stark
kritisiert und argumentiert das in den
Sitten seiner Zeit eine schändliche und
trügerische Gleichförmigkeit herrsche
alle Geister scheinen geradezu nach
demselben Muster zugeschnitten zu sein
also es geht um Oberflächlichkeit um
fehlende Authentizität nur die
Höflichkeit das sind lauter
Äußerlichkeiten lauter ja
beigebrachte Verhaltensweisen die aber
gar nicht ernst gemeint sind nur solche
Gepflogenheiten die völlig unauthentisch
sind und die nicht der eigenen Eingebung
der Natürlichkeit der Originalität der
Ursprünglichkeit entspringen das ist
seine Kritik also es gibt hier nur die
Herde nur die Massenphänomene der
soziale Zwang und das freie natürlich
Individuum das
existiert nicht mehr in dieser
Situation der
Wissenschaft und der Künste des 18
Jahrhunderts und dabei sollte man doch
denken dass 18 Jahrhundert hat doch die
Aufklärung hervorgebracht und damit auch
die Sitten verbessert muss so bestreitet
das mit einigen Argumenten die wir uns
jetzt genau anschauen wollen er sagt das
die Wissenschaften und die Künste dazu
beigetragen haben dass keine aufrichtige
Wertschätzung mehr existiert weil wir
uns natürlich immer miteinander
vergleichen das führt auf eine andere
Kritik von Russo dass wir am nicht mehr
im Naturzustand Leben sondern im
Vernunft Zustand und dass wir
kein natürliche Selbstliebe mehr haben
aber wir sind Naturzustand hatten
sondern nur noch eine vergleichende
Eigenliebe also wir vergleichen uns
immer mit anderen sind wir reicher
besser könnte hinzufügen schöner
erfolgreicher und das verdirbt
unseres Zusammenlebens Verdächtigungen
sagte arg wohl Befürchtungen
Gefühlskälte Zurückhaltung hast Verrat
werden sich unablässig hinter diesem
gleichförmigen und trügerischen
Deckmantel der Höflichkeit verstecken
ich mag wieder erinnern an dieses
Eingangszitat wir täuschen uns unter dem
Schein des richtigen also der Deckmantel
der Höflichkeit dahinter
hinter diese Urbanität auch die
Stadtstruktur die eine ganzen neue Form
von Zusammenleben erfordert wo man sehr
eng miteinander Zusammenleben muss und
immer hat auch den Blicken der anderen
ausgesetzt ist Erwartungshaltung
ausgesetzt ist die verdanken wir dem
aufgeklärten jahrhundert im 18
Jahrhundert und das sind keine positiven
Folgen für die sittens sagt jetzt wo so
auch am kritisiert er dass
das aufklärende Licht
je mehr es aufgestiegen ist als er
bedient sich hier dieser Metaphorik
machen Link oben rechtsfreien zu der
ersten Sitzung wo wir diese Metapher der
Aufklärung genauer auch bildlich
analysiert hatten also je mehr das
aufklärende Licht
erscheint durchbricht durch die Wolken
umso mehr ist die Tugend sagt er dahin
geschwunden und es ist nicht nur ein
Charakteristik und das 18 Jahrhunderts
sondern das ist noch so eine
grundgesetzlichkeit die die gesamte
Menschheitsgeschichte durchzieht und
strukturiert
er kritisiert die Dekadenz die
Oberflächlichkeit Luxus Sittenverfall
und Versklavung
die mit dieser glücklichen Unwissenheit
einhergehen aus der wir herausgehen
wollen also die ewige Weisheit die mit
der Aufklärung in verbunden Verbindung
gebracht werden kann ist jetzt eben nach
so gar nicht die aufgeklärte Vernunft
sondern eher die natürliche Einrichtung
dass wir durch die Natur
geschützt wurden er sagt die Natur
wollte euch ihr Menschen vor der
Wissenschaft bewahren ebenso wie eine
Mutter ihren Kind eine gefährliche Waffe
Aussehen Händen reißt also wir waren in
einer glücklichen Unwissenheit und
haben jetzt durch die Aufklärung
Mittel zur Verfügung bekommen den wir
nicht gewachsen sind und die dazu führen
dass wir in unserem Zusammenleben immer
unsittlicher werden das ist eine
Gesellschaftskritik kritisiert auch die
Bildung seiner Zeit
die Bildung sagte verdirrt unsere
Urteilskraft er sieht nur Anstalten also
Bildungseinrichtungen wenn die gar nicht
mehr
wirklich auf Moralität achten Kinder
lernen nicht mehr ihre eigene Sprache
sondern nur noch fremde Sprachen
künstlichen Sprachen erdenkt natürlich
an die alten Sprachen Latein und
Griechisch interessanterweise stellt er
seinen Traktat seinen Preisschrift ein
lateinisches Zitat voran ist das
vielleicht ein Widerspruch also sie
haben kein Verständnis für das was sie
lernen Sie
amen das nur nach sie sind nicht
authentisch und sie verstehen sich auf
spitzfindige Argumente also sophistic
und sie
bewirken damit dass wir nicht mehr klar
zwischen Irrtum und Wahrheit
unterscheiden können auch solche
moralischen sittlichen Begriffe wie
Großherzigkeit Gerechtigkeit mäßig
müssen alles Tugenden Menschlichkeit und
Mut haben die Bedeutung verloren das ist
eine Kritik an der Bildungssituation
auch herstelle Oberflächlichkeit die
nicht mehr auf den moralischen Status
der Menschen abzielt sondern nur noch
auf die Leistungsfähigkeit was vermag
diese Person
wie viel Nutzen bringt sie
ja das ist die etliche ökologischen
Nutzen bringt und auch nur die Schönheit
die Ästhetik zählt und nicht mehr
wirklich das dahinterstehende eigentlich
entscheidende was unsere Tugend und
Moral betreffend
das war jetzt eine kurze Übersicht über
die wichtigsten Kritikpunkte von Russo
zusammengefasst er wird die These das 18
Jahrhundert die Aufklärung der Vernunft
der Fortschritte der Wissenschaften hat
eben gerade nicht dazu beigebracht dass
wir unsere Sitten verbessern warum weil
er argumentiert dass die neuen
Wissenschaften die Vernunft dazu führen
uns mit anderen immer zu vergleichen
Neid unmoralische Gefühle entstehen zu
lassen das heißt wir brauchen nicht
meine Aufklärung unseres Verstandes
unsere Kultur sondern in einem Wort eine
Aufklärung unseres Herzens dafür
argumentiert so